Diane you were telling me something
about a certain tests like it's almost
like a litmus test to see how
female-friendly a film is and I was
fascinated to hear more about it yeah so
this test I'm i hope i'm going to
pronounce it right is the bechdel it
might be the best ow test and i first
read about it and not long after I'm a
total idiot test asks the first question
is are there two women in the movie and
if there are do they both have names and
then the second question is if they both
if there are two women in the movie and
they both have names and most movies
actually fail on that first question
okay but the site questions if there are
do they talk to each other and like I
think then it's something like you know
ninety percent of movies fail at
something and then the third question is
and if there are these two women and
they do talk to each other is it about
something other than men and you know
this is like an interesting test that I
think really highlights for people like
the extent of the problem that we have
you know like we're just not really
aware of it and then you when you ask
these questions they seem so basic and
you realize most movies don't have that
you guys this is a bit of a mess I
realize myself with my first film that
it failed the test so there are two
women in obsidia they do have names but
they never meet and they never talk to
each other so and I was really like when
I when I realized that I really I felt
like just kind of devastated because you
know I feel so strongly about sort of
women's issues and I just I right then I
was like okay that's never gonna happen
again and what am I felt right you know
it's like if that's that's not happening
and I deliberately set out I actually I
wrote one film which went to the Sundown
screenwriters lab that was about two
sisters called stem which we're still
hoping Goodman times produce probably
2016 and then I wrote this other one
about two women who meet who are who
find out their biological sisters its
and that was also for me I mean the
movie is completely driven by a sort of
feminist agenda in a certain sense you
know it was partly based on my real
experiences as a yoga teacher teaching
in a social welfare Center for
prostitutes and kind of what I've
witnessed there and you know some of the
women that I fell
we're living with extraordinary levels
of violence in their life and how that
seemed acceptable in our society that
these women live like that and everyone
just sort of turns a blind eye and says
well you know that's their life the
numbers of women who are killed by their
partners every month you know and so
this the movie definitely came from that
place but I think it's just really
important I realized for myself it's
that thing that we talked about be the
change you know if you're not happy with
the fact that there's not more women in
films then it's your duty to make sure
that if you make a film there are you
know and i think you know each of us as
filmmakers and creators we have a
responsibility the film's we make they
don't just reflect our reality they also
create it you know you're part of like
creating what you think society is when
you make a film you're not just holding
up a mirror to it and saying this is how
it is you know it's like it's also like
what it becomes and I think it's really
really important that people are aware
of that you know and if you're a
screenwriter and you're writing a script
you'll just ask yourself it's like you
know you know could this character be a
woman is there any reason why not I
think if I was doing absolutely now I
probably have the scientist be a woman
you know and you know it wouldn't have
you know the story would be exactly the
same like and just with how I feel now
about it and the knowledge that I have I
would probably like that's probably
something that I would have done you
know and something that will do in the
future like I'm just like from now on
you know that's something to be really
conscious about and also to the
character choices of the females that
you portray because there's definitely
women in films but it seems like there a
certain stereotype often especially you
know I mean nothing did not you know not
tonight bridesmaids or whatever but
there's just sort of the funny girl the
the Mean Green there's nothing that's
necessarily like a role model well I
definitely yeah I was very corner stuff
that when I was making my this second
film like I wanted this woman like I
wanted a story about a woman who rescues
another woman and I felt like it is
definitely for me a film that is kind of
a celebration of female friendship and
sisterhood and you know what women
should do for each other and I really I
did want it I very consciously wanted to
make that
because I'm so like indebted and so
grateful to all my female friends and
sisters in this world I definitely
wanted to do something to where you see
a woman doing something heroic and like
I just feel like I've seen so many
movies where you know it's a guy goes to
rescue a woman and that sort of story
plays out again and again and women are
always victims and need men to solve
their murders and need men to you know
also just put out all the men are the
ones who have murdered them you know and
I just thought I just really wanted to
see you know to see something different
to create a different narrative about a
woman who decides to help another woman
and whatever the cost is to her
personally she is willing to bear it
because she knows it's the right thing
to do when you presented this story out
in the world how were those characters
perceived were they ever told to maybe
can you play it down a little can you
hit make her a little more girly or or
or could you make her like this or that
i mean i think i was quite lucky like I
mean to be honest the road to production
with that movie was pretty fast like I
pitched the idea our son was three
months old I pitched the idea to
producer a producer Greg Vaughn who is
phenomenal who immediately got on board
to develop the movie and then we were
very lucky that when we were ready to go
out with the script which I think was
maybe maybe like eight months later or
something nine months later we had a
script that we were ready to you know to
raise finance with the very first
company we went to wanted to finance the
movie and they they totally got behind
division I mean I think that was one of
the things that they got them excited
about it and obviously because there was
two very strong female parts in the in
the script we were able to get like
amazing actresses even though it's not a
you know like a high-budget movie we got
two phenomenal actress Jessica Biel and
Zosia Mamet who are just amazing and you
know and obviously they were drawn to it
because they're you know they don't get
the opportunity to play these kinds of
models very often
and that read the script wanted to do it
most of them yeah I mean you know
because it's that thing if there's
there's there's not an there's not
enough like multi-layered yeah roles for
women or the dynamics because I'm not
competing over a man yeah and they had
dimensional characters they were they
were fully flushed out they had good
dimensions to them they weren't just you
know bland they were very colorful it is
kind of you know half the story does
half of that movie is kind of like a
love story between these two women and
no in a romantic sense and I felt that
was something really important to show
and to share that and you know that that
happens and there's you know did it's
you know that friendship that can evolve
between two people you know there's such
a powerful and beautiful thing so I
really wanted to celebrate on a movie
you